OK, so we're going to try something different today. Something we have never tried on our show. And I got the idea for this from a conversation that I had with Jiayang Fan. Jiayang did a story for our show a little while back. And she's not somebody who's normally on the radio. She's a magazine writer.
好的，今天我们尝试点不一样的。这是我们节目中从未尝试过的。这个点子源于我和贾扬·范（Jiayang Fan）的一次对话。贾扬前阵子为我们的节目写了一个故事。她通常不在电台工作，她是位杂志撰稿人。
And so when time came for her to record her script, she sat in the studio with one of our producers, Diane Wu, who had her read. And you know, it's a weird thing to sound, like, relaxed and natural while reading words off a page in a totally soundproof room, hearing your voice on headphones. And Diane did with Jiayang what we always do. She'd tell her, you know, go back and do that sentence a little looser. Or you know, underline this word or whatever. And that just hit something in Jiayang in this way that doesn't usually happen.
当她开始录制脚本时，她和我们的制作人黛安·吴（Diane Wu）坐在录音室里，黛安负责指导她朗读。你知道，在一个完全隔音的房间里，戴着耳机听自己的声音，同时还要读着纸上的文字，却要听起来轻松自然，这其实是很奇怪的感觉。黛安对贾扬做着我们平时会做的事情。她会告诉她：“再来一遍，那句话读得再放松一点，”或者“给这个词加个重音”之类的。这在某种程度上触动了贾扬，产生了不同寻常的效果。
Having a fellow Asian-American who looks exactly like me coach me through that process, hearing exactly how much more American she sounded than me, it made me think anew about my voice and the way I speak English.
让一位长相和我一模一样的亚裔美国同胞来指导我完成这个过程，听着她比我听起来“美国味”浓得多，这让我重新思考了自己的声音以及我说英语的方式。
OK. I have a bunch of things to say to that. First of all, this idea that you and Diane look exactly the same, that's racist. You do not.
好吧，对此我有很多话想说。首先，关于你和黛安长得一模一样这种想法，这可是种族主义。你们长得根本不像。
Fair point. Fair point.
有道理。说得对。
And then it's interesting to me that you perceived it as--
而且我很有兴趣知道，你为什么会觉得……
Jiayang has thought a lot about the way that she speaks English and the way that others do, going back to when she was seven years old and she came to the United States from China. This was in the '90s in a mostly white part of New Haven. And it was just understood, she said, that it was her job in the family to learn to speak perfect, accentless English as soon as possible.
贾扬对自己说英语的方式以及他人的表达方式思考了很多，这要追溯到她七岁从中国来到美国的时候。那是90年代，她住在纽黑文一个大部分是白人的社区。她说，当时家里默认的一件事就是：她作为家庭成员的职责，就是尽快学会说出完美、没有口音的英语。
And my mom and some of her peers had said, oh, you have this very narrow window in which your tongue can adjust to the new language or not, because Chinese is so different than English. And I really-- because I was seven or eight at the time, I really didn't even think of it as in the brain. I thought about it as the rigidity of my tongue. And I was so afraid of my tongue literally hardening in my mouth and not being able to contort to this language. And I think it immediately becomes a test of your ability to survive and thrive in this new environment.
我妈和她的一些同龄人曾说，调整舌头以适应新语言的黄金期非常短暂，因为中文和英语差别太大了。我当时才七八岁，甚至没觉得这是大脑的问题，我以为是舌头太僵硬了。我非常害怕我的舌头在嘴里真的变硬，以至于无法适应这种语言。我觉得这瞬间变成了一种在陌生环境生存和发展的能力测试。
How well you can speak without an accent.
看你能在没有口音的情况下说得多好。
Right. Like I've been told, OK, look, you're going to be living in water for the rest of your life. Well, the better you can swim, kind of-- I better get a few different kinds of strokes under my belt.
没错。就像有人对我说：“好了，你看，你这辈子都得在水里生活了。嗯，你游得越好……我最好多学几种游泳姿势。”
And when you view that whole attitude now, like, how do you see it?
现在回看这种心态，你觉得如何？
The adult me doesn't necessarily endorse the goal of speaking accentless English and the need to fit into the perfect American ideal, whatever that is. But that was what my parents thought was necessary to protect me in a foreign country.
现在的我并不一定认同那种“必须说纯正地道英语”以及“需要融入完美美国理想（不管那是什么）”的目标。但那是当时我父母认为为了在外国保护我所必需做的事情。
Jiayang did the hard work of mastering the countless little subtleties of pronunciation and usage to the point where she thought she sounded more or less like native English speakers. Friends, especially white friends, told her she didn't have an accent. And when she herself had little twinges of like, oh, maybe I sound different, she shrugged it off as being too hard on herself.
贾扬付出了艰辛的努力，掌握了无数细微的发音和用法，以至于她认为自己听起来和母语人士差不多了。朋友们，特别是白人朋友，告诉她她没有口音。当她自己偶尔感到“哦，我可能听起来有点不一样”时，她也只是耸耸肩，觉得是自己对自己太苛刻了。
And hearing my voice on the radio, hearing myself speak, it was a very rude awakening. It was embarrassing and slightly mortifying. Like, I do sound different, even when I'm trying really, really hard not to.
而在电台里听到自己的声音，听到自己说话，那是一种非常粗暴的觉醒。那让我感到尴尬，甚至有些羞愧。就像，“我确实听起来不一样，即使我非常非常努力地想要避免。”
To be clear, the difference that she heard-- it wasn't that she had an accent like you normally think of an accent. Specifically, what she was hearing was--
说清楚一点，她听到的那种区别——并不是通常认为的那种口音。具体来说，她听到的是……
Over-enunciation. And maybe I was unattuned to how much effort there is in my most casual speech. A huge part of how I sound different is I'm so afraid that if I don't make the sound explicit, I won't be understood. And that process of making it explicit is what actually makes me sound really different, whereas--
过度发音（Over-enunciation）。也许我没有意识到我在日常谈话中投入了多少力气。我听起来不同的很大一部分原因，是我太害怕如果我不把声音发得足够清晰，别人就听不懂。而那种刻意追求清晰的过程，恰恰让我听起来非常不同，而……
It's funny. As you're saying this sentence, I feel so aware of how every final T and every final D, you're actually enunciating.
很有趣。当你现在说这句话时，我注意到你每一个词尾的T和D都在用力发音。
Right. That effortfulness is part of how I speak.
没错。那种用力感正是我的说话方式的一部分。
OK, so we're finally getting to the reason that I'm telling you all this. One night a little while back, I ran into Jiayang at an event. And she explained all this to me and told me how since coming on our show, she was feeling self-conscious about her English in a way that she hadn't for years. But also and more importantly, she was finding herself listening to Chinese-American friends with new ears. Suddenly she was hearing the huge variations in cadence and speech that can give away that you're not a native speaker .
好了，终于说到我告诉你们这些的原因了。不久前的一天晚上，我在一个活动上遇到了贾扬。她向我解释了这一切，并告诉我，自从上了我们的节目，她对自己的英语感到了一种多年未有的局促。更重要的是，她发现自己开始用全新的耳朵去倾听美籍华裔朋友的谈话。她突然听出了说话节奏和表达上的巨大差异，那些差异会让人听出你不是母语人士。
It would come out in the stringing together of certain words. And I became convinced that I could tell how old someone was when they arrived in this country and started speaking English. Because the more fluidly they could pronounce certain words or ride out a cadence, the younger they must have been when they arrived.
这会体现在某些词汇的连读上。我变得确信，我能听出一个人几岁来到这个国家开始说英语。因为他们发音某些词汇或驾驭节奏越流畅，他们来到这里时就一定越年轻。
Yeah, I remember that you said to me that night if you could just hear somebody speak, you would be able to tell them how long they had been in this country or how old they were when they arrived in this country.
是的，我记得那天晚上你跟我说，只要听到某人说话，你就能说出他们在该国居住了多久，或者他们来到该国时有多大。
Right. Their age of arrival.
没错。也就是他们的抵达年龄。
And I said to you at the time, challenge accepted. Do you remember? We were sitting there. I said, if I find let's say three people who moved to this country, could we have you come on the radio and you would guess how old they were when they arrived? And you could exhibit your superpower. And we would find out if, in fact, you were correct.
我当时对你说：“挑战接受。”你还记得吗？我们当时坐在那儿。我说，如果我找来三位移民到这个国家的人，你能来电台猜猜他们抵达时的年龄吗？你可以展示你的超能力。我们会验证你是否准确。
Exactly. And that I could hear in their speech something that they themselves didn't even necessarily hear. And that's what made it sort of magical to me.
没错。我可以从他们的谈话中听出一些他们自己甚至没有察觉的东西。这对我来说有一种魔力。
And so that is what we're here to do today. Jiayang is going to play that game. Maybe the only way she could ever find out once and for all if indeed she can do this. We've created an entire radio game show for that purpose. Let me hear some studio audience, please.
所以这就是我们今天要做的。贾扬要玩这个游戏。这可能是她唯一能一劳永逸地验证自己是否真有这种能力的方法。我们为此专门制作了一个电台游戏节目。请让我听听现场观众的声音。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
And then after doing that, we tried to figure out other experiences that people have that would best be captured not the way we usually do it on our show-- following people around with microphones and recording them, interviewing them-- but in game show format. So we are very excited to bring you something we have never heard of anybody trying, namely, an entire program of stories done as game shows. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
在那之后，我们试图找出人们的其他经历，这些经历最好不是通过我们通常的方式——带着麦克风跟拍、采访——而是以游戏节目的形式呈现。所以，我们非常兴奋地为你们带来一个我们从未听说过有人尝试过的节目，即整个节目内容都以游戏形式呈现。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《This American Life》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Act 1, With Great Power Comes Great Pronounceability. OK, so we came up with this game to test Jiayang's claim. And Tobin Low, one of the editors on our program-- he's also Chinese-American-- got excited about the idea and volunteered to be our Bob Barker, our Alex Trebek for the game. And so I hand it off to him.
第一幕，强大的发音能力。好了，我们设计了这个游戏来测试贾扬的说法。托宾·洛（Tobin Low），我们节目的编辑之一——他也是美籍华裔——对这个想法很兴奋，并自愿担任我们的鲍勃·巴克（Bob Barker）和亚历克斯·特雷贝克（Alex Trebek）。所以我把话筒交给他。
Welcome, ladies and gentlemen. I am Tobin Low. Hello, audience.
女士们、先生们，欢迎光临。我是托宾·洛。大家好，观众们。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Welcome to a game we are calling Date of Arrival, in which Jiayang Fan tells you when you immigrated to the United States. Jiayang, welcome. How are you feeling? Are you feeling confident?
欢迎来到我们称之为“抵达日期”的游戏，在这个游戏中，贾扬·范要猜出你是什么时候移民到美国的。贾扬，欢迎。感觉如何？有信心吗？
I'm feeling a bit of trepidation, I have to admit. I was pumped for this, but now that the date has arrived, my Asian fear of failure is kicking in.
说实话，我有点忐忑。我本来很兴奋，但现在时间到了，我的亚裔式失败恐惧症开始发作了。
Well, the good news is we have great guests lined up for you today. And if you guess two of them correctly, you're going to win our prize, which is a brand new car.
好消息是，我们今天为你请到了很棒的嘉宾。如果你能猜对其中两个，你将赢得我们的奖品，一辆崭新的汽车。
This only-- this only ups the stakes and my anxiety. I'm hoping that I can channel my anxiety for success.
这只会……这只会增加赌注和我的焦虑。我希望我能把焦虑转化为成功的动力。
It's all good. I have complete faith in you, Jiayang. Are you ready to hear the rules?
没关系。我对你有十足的信心，贾扬。准备好听规则了吗？
Hit me.
放马过来吧。
OK. So each guest is somebody who immigrated to the United States from China at some point in their life. And they have been given up to three sentences to read aloud. So each sentence contains phrases like urban and rural America. And these are phrases that, Jiayang, you picked because they can be challenging to pronounce.
好。每位嘉宾都是在人生某个阶段从中国移民到美国的。他们被要求朗读最多三句话。每句话都包含像“城市和乡村美国”这样的词组。贾扬，这些词组是你挑的，因为它们发音很有挑战性。
Or they are sentences that be very familiar to someone who's lived here for years. And at the end of each sentence, Jiayang, you get a chance to guess at what age they came to the US. If you are within one year of the correct age, we will give you the point. Does that make sense?
或者它们是对于在这儿住过多年的人来说非常熟悉的句子。每句话结束时，贾扬，你有机会猜出他们来到美国时的年龄。如果你猜的年龄在正确年龄的一年误差范围内，我们就给你算一分。听明白了吗？
One year. I mean, that's narrow. But yes, I accept.
一年。太严苛了吧。但好吧，我接受。
OK, great. Well, then we are going to welcome our first guest, Luke Ma. Hi, Luke, how are you? Where are you calling in from?
好的，太棒了。那么，我们欢迎第一位嘉宾，卢克·马（Luke Ma）。嗨，卢克，你好吗？你从哪里打进来的？
Hi, everyone. I'm doing lovely. I'm calling in from San Jose in California.
大家好。我很好。我从加利福尼亚的圣何塞打来的。
Just for a point of reference for Jiayang, how old are you?
为了给贾扬一个参考，你今年多大了？
Oh, yes. I'm 41.
哦，是的，我41岁。
All right. We are going to go ahead and have you read sentence number one.
好的。我们要开始了，请你读第一句。
All right. Here it goes. And I have to say, my Asian fear of failure is kicking in too. Now I feel like I must-- I have to stump-- I have to stump Fan Jiayang, otherwise I won't win.
好的。开始了。我不得不说，我的亚裔失败恐惧症也发作了。现在我觉得我必须……我得难倒范贾扬，否则我赢不了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So sentence one. The airplane flew over urban and rural America.
那么第一句：“飞机飞过了城市和乡村的美国。”
Jiayang, hearing sentence one, are you ready to make a guess?
贾扬，听了第一句，准备好做出猜测了吗？
Not quite, not quite. I think I need a little-- I think I'm going to need a little bit more.
还没完全准备好。我想我需要……我想我还需要更多一点。
All right. Great.
好的，太棒了。
Here you go. Sentence two. Got my hands up. They're playing my song. I know I'm going to be OK. Yeah, it's a party in the USA.
给你。第二句：“举起双手。他们正在放我的歌。我知道我会没事的。是的，那是美国的一场派对。”
OK, great. That's more information. I'm going to have to go all the way for sentence number three. I think I'm going to need as much information as I can wrangle.
好的，太棒了。那信息更多了。我得坚持到第三句。我想我需要尽可能多地获取信息。
All right. Sentence number three. Peter Piper picked a peck of pickled peppers.
好的。第三句：“彼得·派珀（Peter Piper）摘了一啄腌辣椒。”
OK, so can I reach for my lifeline?
好吧，我可以请求求助吗？
Yes. OK, so this is a secret lifeline that we are going to allow Jiayang to access, which is that Luke, we are going to ask you to say her name. That's all we're asking is just say her name.
可以。这是我们要给贾扬的一个秘密求助机会，就是卢克，我们要请你说出她的名字。我们只需要你说她的名字。
Right.
好的。
Sure. Fan Jiayang.
当然。范贾扬。
Oof, OK.
呜，好的。
Curveball, curveball.
变化球，变化球。
I don't know if-- I don't know if that helped or confused, because clearly he is someone--
我不知道这到底是帮了忙还是让我更困惑了，因为很显然他是一个……
Because you don't have an ABC like me just mangling your name left and right.
因为你没有像我这样的ABC，名字被各种乱读。
Because he obviously can speak Chinese, because he pronounced the syllables correctly, but also had a mastery of the tones. But I think I've been given all the information that is permissible. And I think I'm-- I have a number in my head.
因为他显然会说中文，因为他准确地发出了音节，而且掌握了声调。但我想我已经得到了所有允许获得的信息。我心里有个数了。
OK.
好的。
I'm going to go with five.
我猜是五岁。
OK.
好的。
The reasoning here is that Luke has nailed every single sentence. There's no micropause of anxiety when he says urban and rural America. The double R in rural is so natural. And I'm almost tempted to say that he has no accent whatsoever, which is usually the case when you come before the ages of four, five, six.
理由是卢克刚才读的每一句都非常到位。他在说“城市和乡村美国”时没有任何焦虑的微停顿。那个“rural”里的双R发音太自然了。我甚至想说他完全没有口音，这通常发生在四、五、六岁之前就过来的人身上。
OK, final answer is five.
好的，最终答案是五岁。
[HORN BLOWING]
[喇叭响]
Luke, would you like to tell us at what age you moved to the states?
卢克，你想告诉我们你几岁移居美国的吗？
Yeah, I moved to the States at 37. No, I moved to the States at one month before I turned nine.
是的，我是在我九岁生日前一个月移居美国的。
Shit.
该死。
But Fan Jiayang, what you said about my accent is what I think most native speakers and other people have said, which is there doesn't seem to be a discernible accent. And yet somehow in my head, I feel like there is a difference. But I can't really verbalize exactly what that difference is.
但是范贾扬，你对我口音的评价是大多数母语人士和其他人说的话，那就是似乎没有明显的口音。然而不知怎的，在我脑海里，我感觉是有区别的。但我无法确切地说出那种区别到底是什么。
And the only difference I've been able to hone in on in my head is the sense of the ability to drop into a kind of casual, fluid, elided tone in between syllables, where I always feel like my enunciation or the way I speak-- it's just ever so slightly 2% over-enunciated compared to native speakers.
在我脑海中，我能确定的唯一区别是对在音节之间那种随意、流畅、连读的语调的掌控能力，而我总是觉得我的发音或说话方式……与母语人士相比，总是有那么2%的过度发音。
That makes a lot of sense to me. But having said all that, I wonder if you can hear my accent.
这对我来说很有道理。但说了这么多，我好奇你能听出我的口音吗？
So if I were to put it on a spectrum, I feel like the way Tobin speaks, to me, is like native beyond native. It is the most fluid, perfectly expected American sound I can imagine.
如果放在一个光谱上，我觉得托宾说话的方式，对我来说，就是“超越地道的母语”。那是我能想象出的最流畅、完全合乎期待的美国声音。
I'm with you 100% on that. Yes, absolutely. Absolutely. So he is the platonic ideal.
我百分之百同意。是的，绝对的。绝对。所以他是柏拉图式的理想型。
Yeah. His voice, his sound. The structure of his throat is perfect is what we're saying. No, no, if we were-- I think if it were aspirational, Tobin has achieved that last 2% to get to 100.
是的。他的声音，他的发音。我们想说的是，他喉咙的结构是完美的。不，不，如果这是一个追求的目标，托宾已经实现了最后那2%的提升，达到了100%。
He is nirvana, yes.
他是涅槃，是的。
You guys are hitting on every insecurity I've ever had of like talking to other Chinese kids and them being like, oh, wow, you are-- there's nothing there. It's absent. And just being like, OK, thanks, I guess.
你们触碰到了我所有的不安全感，那种和其他华裔孩子说话时，他们说：“噢，哇，你……那里什么都没有。完全没有（口音）。”而我只能说，“好的，谢谢，我想。”
Right. Well, yes. I mean, so you hear yourself as B-plus?
对。好吧，是的。我的意思是，所以你把自己视为B+？
I mean, Asian B-plus. So I hear myself as a 97 or a 98, compared to Tobin's 100.
我是说，亚裔式的B+。所以我把自己视为97或98分，相比托宾的100分。
OK, Asian B-plus. OK, yes. Yes.
好的，亚裔B+。好的，是的。是的。
Yeah. And Fan Jiayang, for you, honestly I feel like I would put you at like a 94 or 93. Like I think this person most likely is an immigrant and probably an Asian-American immigrant.
是的。而范贾扬，老实说，我觉得我会给你打94或93分。我觉得这个人极有可能是个移民，可能是一位亚裔美国移民。
I actually feel very affirmed, because part of listening to yourself is this search for-- and wondering if you hear yourself correctly-- is this question of whether you exist in the same reality, in the same acoustic reality as everyone else. And you gave me like a 93. And I would give myself like a 91. So like the fact that we are both in the same ballpark kind of affirms my sense that OK, I am not crazy. And I'm not living in delusion. You are hearing myself more or less the way that I hear myself.
我其实感到非常被认可，因为倾听自己的一部分过程就是这种寻找——并怀疑自己是否听得准确——这也是一个关于我是否与其他人处于同一个现实、同一个声学现实中的问题。你给了我93分。而我会给自己打91分。所以我们都在同一个范围内，这证实了我的感觉：好的，我没疯。我也没活在幻想里。你听到我的方式和我听到自己的方式差不多。
OK, unfortunately we have to move on. Luke, thank you so much for joining us.
好的，很遗憾我们得继续了。卢克，非常感谢你的加入。
I'm glad I could be of some use.
很高兴我能有所帮助。
All right, so we are on to guest number two now. So we're going to welcome Frank. Hi, Frank.
好的，我们现在进行第二位嘉宾。欢迎弗兰克（Frank）。嗨，弗兰克。
Hi.
你好。
Hi, Frank.
嗨，弗兰克。
Frank, could I ask you to introduce yourself?
弗兰克，我能请你介绍一下自己吗？
Sure. Frank Shong. I'm 55.
当然。弗兰克·松（Frank Shong）。我55岁。
And where are we reaching you, Frank?
弗兰克，你在哪里打进来的？
In the San Francisco Bay Area.
在旧金山湾区。
Frank, could you go ahead and read sentence number one for us?
弗兰克，你可以为我们读第一句吗？
Yeah, sentence one. The airplane flew over urban and rural America.
好的，第一句。飞机飞过了城市和乡村的美国。
Jiayang, after sentence one, are you ready to make a guess?
贾扬，第一句之后，准备好做出猜测了吗？
I think I have a sense of the ballpark. But I would love additional data. So I'm going to go on to ask for the second sentence.
我想我有个大致范围。但我很乐意得到额外数据。所以我请求读第二句。
All right. So this is two. Got my hands up. They're playing my song. I know I'm going to be OK. Yeah, it's a party in the USA.
好的。这是第二句：举起双手。他们正在放我的歌。我知道我会没事的。是的，那是美国的一场派对。
OK, that was sentence two. How are you feeling, Jiayang?
好的，那是第二句。感觉如何，贾扬？
I think I'm ready to make a guess.
我想我已经准备好猜测了。
Wow, OK, after sentence two. Bold move.
哇，好的，第二句之后。大胆的举动。
I think that I would like to go with 19.
我想我猜19岁。
OK, can you explain your reasoning?
好的，你能解释一下理由吗？
Sure. I could hear the way that he really lingered on urban and rural. Even though he said both those words fine, I can hear the effort. I don't think he came here as a child. And on top of that, I can detect the hint of an English accent. And I wonder if Frank is someone who either spent time in Hong Kong, which was formerly a British colony, or went through an educational system that had British English instruction. And then maybe came here as a young adult, because I can tell that he's absolutely fluent in the language.
当然。我听得出他在“城市”和“乡村”这两个词上的拖长。尽管他把这两个词说得很好，但我能听出那种刻意的努力。我不认为他是孩提时代过来的。更重要的是，我能检测到一丝英国口音。我好奇弗兰克是否是在香港待过，那里曾是英国殖民地，或者经历了接受英式英语教育的体制。然后可能是作为年轻成人来到这里的，因为我能看出他的英语非常流利。
Gotcha. OK, so 19, final answer.
明白了。好的，19岁，最终答案。
Yes.
是的。
OK. Here's what I'm going to say. Technically, based on the rules of the game, you got it wrong.
好的。我要说的是：从技术上讲，根据游戏规则，你猜错了。
[HORN BLOWING]
[喇叭响]
But you're damn close. Frank came at age 22. And I am very tempted to give you the point, because of some of the reasoning you gave.
但你非常接近。弗兰克是在22岁时来的。我非常想给你这一分，因为你给出的某些理由。
Yeah.
是的。
So like maybe that's a place to start. Frank, can you talk a little bit about learning English and that process for you?
也许这是一个开始。弗兰克，你能聊聊你学习英语的过程吗？
Yeah, so when I was young when they decided to put English back into the curriculum after the Cultural Revolution, we really didn't have much material from the US. So anyone who lived in China my age or above would know that's the age of the material from the BBC. And so that's where I picked up my accent.
好的，当我年轻时，他们决定在文化大革命后将英语放回课程，我们真的没有多少来自美国的教材。所以任何我这个年龄或以上在中国生活过的人都知道，那时接触的教材来自BBC。所以我的口音就是从那里学的。
That's interesting. And the irony of it is that I grew up in-- I was born in '84. And I grew up when the only Chinese you were supposed to speak was state-mandated, like accentless Mandarin. Do you remember?
这很有趣。讽刺的是，我出生于84年。我长大时，唯一允许说的中文是国家指定的，像没有口音的普通话。你还记得吗？
Yeah.
是的。
So you weren't supposed to speak any regional accent at all. And that's the Mandarin that I speak, kind of completely devoid of any regional accent.
所以你根本不应该说任何地方口音。这就是我说的普通话，某种程度上完全没有任何地方口音。
I disagree with that.
我不赞同。
Oh, really? How so?
噢，真的吗？怎么说？
Because in my effort to look up Jiayang's videos, I saw one of you interviewing restaurants in Chinatown.
因为我为了查找贾扬的视频，看到一个你在唐人街采访餐馆的片段。
Yes.
是的。
So in my view, you have less of an accent in English than your accent in Chinese.
所以在我看来，你的英语口音比你的中文口音要少。
Well, this is a plot twist. What do you mean? What do you hear in my Chinese?
好吧，这可是情节反转。你什么意思？你在我的中文里听到了什么？
For instance, the jeh che tse distinction, you don't really try to make that clear.
例如，舌尖前音和舌尖后音的区别，你并没有真正尝试把它表达清楚。
Wow.
哇。
Oh, wow. Yes. But you don't hear like an American accent in my Chinese.
噢，哇。是的。但你没听出我的中文有美国口音吧？
Right. Right, not an American accent but a--
对，对，不是美国口音，而是一种……
Southern.
南方口音。
Right. Yes.
没错，是的。
Phew. Phew, Frank, because if you were going to accuse me of having an American accent--
呼。呼，弗兰克，因为如果你要指责我有美国口音……
Sorry, sorry.
抱歉，抱歉。
In Chinese, that was really going to throw me for a loop.
在中文里，那真的会让我很抓狂。
And on that note--
说起那个……
On that note, thank you so much, Frank. It was a real pleasure chatting.
说起那个，非常感谢你，弗兰克。聊天真是太愉快了。
Thank you guys.
谢谢你们。
We are ready for our next guest. Please welcome Larissa. Hi, Larissa.
我们准备好迎接下一位嘉宾。欢迎拉丽莎（Larissa）。嗨，拉丽莎。
Hi there.
嗨。
Hi, Larissa.
嗨，拉丽莎。
Yeah, my name is Larissa Jo. I'm 35. No, wait, am I 35? I'm 34.
是的，我叫拉丽莎·乔（Larissa Jo）。我35岁。不，等等，我35岁吗？我34岁。
OK, so we are ready to jump in. Larissa, if you would, could you read sentence number one?
好的，我们准备好开始了。拉丽莎，如果可以的话，请读第一句。
The airplane flew over urban and rural America.
飞机飞过了城市和乡村的美国。
I'm definitely going to need the second sentence, Tobin.
我肯定需要第二句，托宾。
Larissa, can you read sentence number two?
拉丽莎，你能读第二句吗？
Got my hands up. They were playing my song. I know I'm going to be OK. Yeah, it's a party in the USA.
举起双手。他们正在放我的歌。我知道我会没事的。是的，那是美国的一场派对。
OK, that's sentence two.
好的，那是第二句。
Yes. And I'm going to go for sentence number three as well.
是的。我也想要第三句。
Peter Piper picked a peck of pickled peppers.
彼得·派珀摘了一啄腌辣椒。
OK. I think I'm going to go for 10.
好的。我想我猜10岁。
OK.
好的。
I'm thinking out loud. I think this one is a bit challenging.
我正在思考。我觉得这一条有点难。
Here's what I'll offer. Would you like to talk to Larissa a little bit more before locking in your answer?
我提供一个建议。你愿意在锁定答案前和拉丽莎再多聊聊吗？
Yes. Oh, yes, some mercy.
好的，好的，真是仁慈。
OK. Larissa, can I prompt then? Larissa, the last time we talked, you told a story about volunteering for a local library at some point. Could you tell that story?
好的。拉丽莎，我能提示一下吗？拉丽莎，上次我们谈话时，你讲过关于在当地图书馆做志愿者的故事。能讲讲那个吗？
I was volunteering to become an audiobook recorder at the Washington Talking Book and Braille Library. This was when I lived in Seattle. And you have to audition for it. You basically just read some passages. And later the volunteer coordinator got back to me and they said, yeah, the judges, they are hesitant to accept you because they don't know where you're from. But they know you're not from around here. They know you're not American. But they can't tell where.
我当时自愿成为华盛顿有声读物和盲文图书馆的录音师。那是在我住在西雅图的时候。你必须为此试镜。你基本上就是读一些段落。后来志愿者协调员联系我，他们说，是的，评委们犹豫是否要接受你，因为他们不知道你来自哪里。但他们知道你不是本地人。他们知道你不是美国人。但他们说不出你是哪儿的人。
That was actually really helpful. Tobin, if I may--
那真的很有帮助。托宾，如果可以的话……
Yes.
好的。
I'm going to alter my guess. And I will give you my explanation. I'm going to say-- I'm deciding between 15 and 16. I just can't quite pull the trigger. I'm going to go for 16.
我打算改变猜测。我会给出我的解释。我……我在15和16之间犹豫。我下不了决心。我决定猜16岁。
OK, you're going for 16. You're coming up. Can you tell me a little bit why?
好的，你猜16岁。你快到了。能告诉我为什么吗？
It's the way she says the word song. She kind of swallows the G in a way that I don't think a native ever would. So it came out like sung, rather than song. And when that happened, my ears perked up, because that's exactly the way that my mom would have said the word song.
这是她说“歌”这个词的方式。她有点吞掉了G，以一种我觉得母语人士永远不会有的方式。听起来像“sung”，而不是“song”。当那发生时，我的耳朵竖了起来，因为那正是我妈妈说“song”这个词的方式。
OK, you can't see that I am squirming in my seat, because unfortunately you went the wrong direction.
好的，你看不见我坐在座位上扭动，因为很遗憾，你猜反了方向。
No, no.
不，不。
Your guess of 10 years old was closer, because the actual answer was that Larissa moved here when she was seven.
你猜的10岁其实更接近，因为真实的答案是拉丽莎七岁时搬到这里的。
[HORN BLOWING]
[喇叭响]
Oh, that's so frustrating, because that's the age I came here.
噢，那太令人沮丧了，因为那正是我的年龄。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And how aware are you of your accent? I mean, do you feel like you can hear it?
你对自己的口音有多了解？我的意思是，你觉得你能听出来吗？
I would say until that experience which was maybe seven, eight years ago with the recording book, I thought I was camouflaged. I thought I was good. And when I heard that they could tell I didn't sound like I was from the US, I felt-- I don't know, a little disappointed or a little offended. And then I spoke to my boyfriend at the time who is American, grew up in America.
我会说，直到七八年前那次录音书籍的经历，我以为我被“伪装”了。我以为我做得很好。当我听说他们能听出我听起来不像美国人时，我感到……我不知道，有点失望，或者有点被冒犯。后来我和我当时的男朋友谈过，他是美国人，在美国长大。
And I said what, I don't have an accent. I speak really good English. And he said yes, you speak very good English. But you don't speak like an American. And I said, what do you mean? And he said for example, he slurs things. He doesn't enunciate. And then when he pointed this out, he said I enunciate everything.
我说什么？我没有口音。我英语说得很好。他说，是的，你的英语说得很好。但你说话不像美国人。我说，你什么意思？他说，例如，他说话会含糊不清。他不刻意发音。然后当他指出这一点时，他说我什么都发音得太清晰。
And when he said that, was that a moment of recognition? Or were you like, what are you talking about?
当他那么说时，那是一个认知的瞬间吗？还是你觉得，你在说什么？
Yeah. That really makes sense. I think it comes from making sure I am understood in English by my parents and other immigrants, wanting them to understand me.
是的。那真的很有道理。我认为这源于确保我能被我的父母和其他移民理解，我希望他们听懂我。
Right. And I wonder if there's a part of you that wants to have no accent at all. Like ideally, would it be better just to be completely accentless?
对。我好奇你内心深处是否有一部分人希望完全没有口音？比如，如果可以的话，完全没有口音会更好吗？
Yeah. You know, for a long time, my experiences had made me be ashamed of it. And now I'm just like, why? Why? I don't want that. I'm going to stand up for where I come from, the things that shaped me, the things that-- even the experiences that made me enunciate. Because this is something I did to help my community. And now it's really part of me.
是的。你知道，很长一段时间里，我的经历让我为此感到羞耻。而现在我只想说，为什么？为什么？我不想要那样。我要支持我的出身，塑造我的那些事物，那些……甚至让我过度发音的经历。因为这是我为了帮助社区所做的事情。而现在它真正成了我的一部分。
Yeah. No, I really like your logic there and also kind of the evolution of your comfort with how you speak. I mean, it's so interesting to talk to you, because I do feel like I'm talking to a version of myself that brings up all my anxieties about how I speak. But also, my aspiration for self acceptance. There's something about your acceptance of your accent that I find inspirational. It is not this race to be accentless, the way that I fear I have conceived of my journey in English. Like I do feel self-conscious about it.
是的。不，我真的很喜欢你的逻辑，还有你对说话方式舒适度的演变。我的意思是，和你交谈非常有趣，因为我确实觉得自己在和一个版本的自己对话，这勾起了我所有关于说话方式的焦虑。但也勾起了我对自我接纳的渴望。你对口音的接纳让我想到了某种灵感。这不是那种想要完全没有口音的竞赛，就像我害怕的那样，我曾构思过我的英语旅程。我的意思是，我确实为此感到局促。
Larissa, if there was a piece of advice for Jiayang to get to where you are, is there something that helped you get to where you are?
拉丽莎，如果给贾扬一个建议来达到你现在的境界，有什么东西能帮助你达到现在这个位置吗？
Oh, that's a great question.
噢，那是个好问题。
Yeah. So I guess maybe I would say-- so why do I have this accent? Why do I speak this way? And I say, well, it's because I lived in China for seven years. And then I say, well, if I don't want an accent, the way to not have it is to wish I hadn't lived in China. And to wish that I was maybe born in the States or something. And do I wish that? And I say, no, I don't wish that. So I want the experiences that also gave me this side effect of the way I speak. And they're an emblem, they're like a memory of that.
是的。我想也许我会说……我为什么有这个口音？我为什么这样说话？我会说，嗯，这是因为我在中国住了七年。然后我说，嗯，如果我不想要口音，不想要它的方式就是希望我没有在中国住过。希望我是在美国出生的什么的。我希望那样吗？我说，不，我不希望。所以我想要那些也给了我这种说话方式副作用的经历。它们是一个象征，它们就像那段记忆。
Thank you, Larissa. You are-- I feel like I'm meeting my future self, the person that I would-- the comfort with my accent that I am aspiring to be. So it's been a real pleasure to talk.
谢谢你，拉丽莎。你……我觉得我遇见了未来的自己，那个我想要成为的……对自己的口音有着舒适感的自己。所以交谈真是太愉快了。
OK. So three contestants. I hate to add insult to injury. But I do have to say your score was zero for three. Maybe this is the time I should tell you, you will not be winning the brand new car. But also the car was going to be just a rental that we were going to give to you for the weekend.
好的。所以三位参赛者。我不忍心伤口撒盐，但我不得不说你的比分是三投零中。也许现在我该告诉你，你赢不到那辆新车。而且那辆车本来也只是我们给你周末租的一辆车。
You've spared me from having to wrangle a friend into being my driver for the rental.
你帮我省去了还得找个朋友来当租车司机的麻烦。
Well, Jiayang, thank you for playing our game. I would say see you next time, but I think we've learned that this game is impossible. And we would discourage it. No one should ever play this game ever again. Shut it down. Good night, audience. We'll see you not next time.
嗯，贾扬，谢谢你玩我们的游戏。我会说下次见，但我想我们已经学到了这个游戏是不可能的。我们建议任何人再也别玩这个游戏了。结束吧。晚安，观众们。我们下次……不一定见。
Thank you, Tobin.
谢谢你，托宾。
Tobin Low is one of the editors of our show. Coming up, can a simple game show save the world? We find out. That's in a minute. Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
托宾·洛是我们节目的编辑之一。接下来，简单的游戏节目能拯救世界吗？我们拭目以待。那是一分钟后的事情。芝加哥公共电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, it's a game show. An entire program of stories presented not the way we usually do, but as game shows, radio game shows. We've arrived at Act Two of our show. And we're calling Act Two--
这里是《This American Life》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，这是一个游戏节目。一个充满故事的节目，不是以我们通常的方式，而是作为游戏节目，电台游戏节目呈现。我们来到了节目的第二幕。我们称之为……
You Bet Your Planet's Life.
“拿你的行星生命打赌”。
That's George Gray, who agreed to take a little time out from his day job as the announcer of The Price Is Right to help us with this next game. And before I get to it, I should explain that this one comes from a question that I have had myself about this thing that I've seen in the news. You know the Paris Agreement on climate change and how it has these goals that countries are supposed to meet if we're going to hold the planet to less than two degrees of warming overall and ideally just 1.5 degrees of warming?
那是乔治·格雷（George Gray），他同意从他的全职工作——《价格猜猜看》（The Price Is Right）播音员——中抽空出来帮助我们完成下一个游戏。在我开始之前，我应该解释一下，这源于我自己对新闻中看到的一件事的疑问。你知道《巴黎协定》关于气候变化的规定，以及它设定的目标，如果我们想把全球变暖控制在两度以内，理想情况下仅在1.5度以内，各国必须实现这些目标？
And I've wondered for a while now. Is there any chance at all, any chance, that the United States is going to make the goals? Like forget about the rest of the world for a minute. Just talking about the part of this that we in this country control. Will we as a country, one of the biggest carbon emitters, will we make our goal?
我有一段时间都在想：美国有一丁点可能实现这些目标吗？忘记世界其他地方，只谈我们国家能控制的那部分。我们国家，作为最大的碳排放国之一，会实现我们的目标吗？
To do that, we would have to cut our emissions by 50% by the year 2030 for starters. That's just eight years from now. Is there any kind of realistic path that gets us there? Well, today's game show episode seemed like a perfect opportunity to finally find out. And so with that in mind, we turn to our next game show.
要做到这一点，我们首先必须在2030年之前将排放量削减50%。距离现在只有八年了。有什么现实的路径能让我们达到那里吗？好吧，今天的游戏节目似乎是一个完美的机会来最终找出答案。带着这个想法，我们转向下一个游戏节目。
Welcome to You Bet Your Planet's Life. Is there any chance at all, ladies and gentlemen, that we will actually make our goals and cut our emissions to half? Well, stay tuned, because today we find out and win valuable prizes.
欢迎来到“拿你的行星生命打赌”。女士们、先生们，我们真的有可能实现目标并将排放量减半吗？敬请收听，因为今天我们要揭晓答案，并赢得宝贵奖品。
Well, thank you, George Gray, for that nice intro. And why don't we bring on today's contestant?
好吧，感谢乔治·格雷带来的精彩开场。为什么不请出今天的参赛者呢？
Well, Ira, hailing from New York City and Austin, Texas, director of research at Columbia University's Center on Global Energy Policy, she's modeled parts of the climate and energy future and worked around the globe for the US government, the International Energy Agency and the Asia-Pacific Energy Research Center. Say that three times fast. Please welcome Melissa Lott. Come on down.
好吧，艾拉，她来自纽约市和得克萨斯州奥斯汀，是哥伦比亚大学全球能源政策中心的研究主任。她模拟过气候和能源的未来，并为美国政府、国际能源署和亚太能源研究中心在世界各地工作过。把它快速说三遍。欢迎梅丽莎·洛特（Melissa Lott）。快请进。
Well, welcome, Melissa. And I hope you're ready to play.
欢迎，梅丽莎。希望你准备好开始游戏了。
I'm excited, Ira. Ready to go.
我很兴奋，艾拉。准备好了。
Now I understand that you are a super taster. Was there a moment where you discovered that?
据我了解你是一位超级品鉴师。有什么瞬间让你发现这一点吗？
There was a moment. I was eating a piece of chocolate. And I went to my friend, I think this one's from Ecuador. And they went, how on earth do you know that? And I said, well, it's so different than the other one. They're like, no, it's not. They don't taste different. And I was like, they are completely different. And they ran off and got a bunch of different ones for me to try. It turns out I can tell the difference blindfolded.
有一个瞬间。我在吃一块巧克力。我对我朋友说，我想这块是厄瓜多尔的。他们说，你到底是怎么知道的？我说，嗯，它和其他的一点都不一样。他们说，不，没区别。它们尝起来一样。我说，它们完全不同。他们跑去拿了一堆不同的给我试。结果证明我可以蒙着眼辨别出区别。
Well, those are skills that will not aid you in our game today.
好吧，那些技能在今天的游戏中可帮不了你。
Probably not.
大概不会。
And let me ask you to take a look up there in the big board, because in this first round, here's what we're going to do. We're going to try to get to 50% cuts in emissions by the year 2030. Or to be very precise about this, our country's goal for the Paris Agreement is to cut 50 to 52% of where our emissions were back in the year 2005.
请看看大屏幕，因为在第一轮中，我们要这样做：我们要尝试在2030年之前将排放量削减50%。或者更精确地说，我们国家为《巴黎协定》设定的目标是比2005年的排放水平削减50%到52%。
And Melissa, in each of your turns that we're going to do, you will propose a number for the amount of emissions that you think we can cut. And then you'll explain how you think we can cut it. If the judges rule that that's credible, if there's reasonable evidence that your proposal could work at the scale and speed you say it could, you will hear this sound.
梅丽莎，在你进行的每一回合中，你都会提出一个你认为我们可以削减的排放量数字。然后解释你认为我们怎么做才能削减它。如果评委裁定那是可信的，如果证据表明你的提议能在你说得出的规模和速度下起作用，你会听到这个声音。
[DING]
[叮]
And it goes up on the board. If the judges think your plan is bogus, malarkey, impossible, you will hear this sound.
它会出现在板子上。如果评委认为你的计划是假的、胡闹的、不可能的，你会听到这个声音。
[BUZZ]
[嗡]
And we all take one step closer to planetary disaster. No pressure.
然后我们大家都向行星灾难迈进一步。没压力吧。
No pressure at all.
一点压力都没有。
And George, where do we start?
乔治，我们从哪儿开始？
Well, Ira, Melissa's starting our game with 25% already on the board.
嗯，艾拉，梅丽莎已经以25%的基数开启了我们的游戏。
So George, maybe you should explain exactly what that's about. Because this surprised me. I really didn't know this before we all started working on this game show.
乔治，也许你应该解释一下那到底是怎么回事。因为这让我很惊讶。在我们开始制作这个游戏节目之前，我真的不知道这一点。
I'd love to, Ira. Since 2005, we've already reduced our emissions around 18%. That's because of cheap wind power, cheap solar power, cheap natural gas replacing coal. And because states, local communities, and big corporations are making moves to lower their emissions. But wait, there's more. Another 7% or so is locked in and ready to roll by the end of the decade. All told, 18% plus 7% gives you-- carry the 1, move it over to 2-- 25 big percentage points.
我很乐意，艾拉。自2005年以来，我们已经减少了约18%的排放量。那是因为廉价的风能、太阳能、廉价的天然气替代了煤炭。而且是因为各州、地方社区和大型企业正在采取行动降低排放。但还有更多，在十年结束前，另外7%左右已经锁定并准备好实施。总而言之，18%加上7%，得到……进位1，移动到2……25个大百分点。
Yeah, that was news to me. Our emissions have been going down ever since 2007 in this country. But what that means is we are already halfway to our goal of 50% by 2030 before we even start our game.
是的，这对我也算新闻。自2007年以来，我国的排放量一直在下降。但这意味着在我们开始游戏之前，我们已经完成了2030年减排50%目标的一半。
That's right, Ira.
那是正确的，艾拉。
So Melissa, your goal is to credibly get us the next 25% on top of that in just eight years. And let's just jump in. How much do you want to put on the board for your first turn?
所以梅丽莎，你的目标是在短短八年内，在此基础上再可信地获得25%。我们直接开始吧。第一回合你想在板子上放多少？
So I'm going to go for another 15%.
我要再增加15%。
OK, 15%. And how are you going to get that 15%?
好的，15%。你打算如何实现那15%？
So I think that President Biden's big climate and energy law is going to actually get us all the way to that 15%.
我认为拜登总统的气候和能源法案实际上将使我们达到那15%。
Is that true? It'll get us that much?
是真的吗？能达到那么多？
Yeah, so it's called the Inflation Reduction Act. But really, it's the biggest energy and climate legislation we've ever passed. It's massive.
是的，它被称为《通胀削减法案》。但实际上，这是我们有史以来通过的最大规模的能源和气候立法。它是巨大的。
And so how does it do that?
那么它是如何做到的？
So it's a whole host of different things. It's tax credits supporting clean electricity. So I'm talking about solar and wind and nuclear, all the stuff we need to produce zero carbon electricity. And then it gives us a lot of tax credits to bring a lot of electric vehicles on the road. There's tax credits for businesses to help them insulate their buildings, let's say, so they can use less energy in the first place. And there's tax credits for capturing carbon before it actually goes into the atmosphere when we're making stuff like concrete and cement.
它是一系列不同的举措。它是支持清洁电力的税收抵免。所以我说的是太阳能、风能和核能，所有我们需要生产零碳电力的东西。然后它给了我们大量的税收抵免，以使大量的电动汽车上路。还有给企业的税收抵免，帮助他们给建筑物隔热，这样他们就能首先使用更少的能源。还有在制造混凝土和水泥等产品时，在碳排放到大气之前进行捕获的税收抵免。
Wait, is concrete and cement actually kind of a big deal?
等等，混凝土和水泥真的有那么重要吗？
Yeah, it's huge. It's really huge.
是的，非常巨大。真的非常大。
OK, so you're saying that all these things, they'll add up. And these things together get us to 15% of our goals under the Paris Agreement.
好的，所以你说所有这些东西加起来，在《巴黎协定》下加起来就是我们目标的15%。
So some people are saying 10%. Some are saying 20%. I'm good with 15%, right in the middle.
有些人说是10%。有些人说是20%。我选15%，正好在中间。
All right. Let's turn to our judges and see what they say.
好的。看看我们的评委怎么说。
Oh, Ira, the judges say yes.
噢，艾拉，评委们说yes。
[DING]
[叮]
So George, what's Melissa's score?
乔治，梅丽莎的得分是多少？
Well, Ira, the big board is at 40%, which means she needs another 10% to reach our goal of 50% emissions cut.
嗯，艾拉，大屏幕现在是40%，这意味着她还需要10%才能达到我们50%的减排目标。
OK, so now it is your second turn, Melissa. In your second turn, how much do you want to put on the board?
好的，现在是你的第二回合，梅丽莎。第二回合你想在板子上放多少？
I think I'm going to go for it and put up a whole 10%. I'm going to go all the way to 50%.
我想我会全力以赴，放上整整10%。我打算一路达到50%。
OK, all right. Going all the way. Daring. What do you got?
好的，好的。全力以赴。大胆。你有什么打算？
OK, so I should say right off the bat that what I have is a whole hodgepodge of stuff. So it's a lot of different things. And so what I'm looking at doing is saying where do we already have momentum? Where are we already moving and we just need to move a little bit faster? So squeeze a couple more percentage points out of the things that are already working for us.
好的，首先我要说，我手头是一堆各种各样的东西。所以有很多不同的因素。所以我所做的是观察我们哪里已经有了动力？我们在哪里已经行动起来，只需要行动得更快一点？从已经对我们有效的措施中再挤出几个百分点。
OK, which means what?
好的，这意味着什么？
So this means three buckets to me. So the first one is electricity. So it's doing all the stuff that's in the Inflation Reduction Act, but pushing it further. Building more solar, more wind, more nuclear, storing more electricity.
这意味着对我来说有三个领域。第一个是电力。所以做所有《通胀削减法案》里提到的事情，但更进一步。建设更多的太阳能、风能、核能，储存更多的电力。
OK, bucket two.
好的，领域二。
So bucket two is about working with just a few big industries. So the ones that produce a lot of greenhouse gases. How do we work with them to get their emissions down really quickly?
领域二关于与几个大行业合作。就是那些产生大量温室气体的行业。我们如何与他们合作以非常快速地降低排放？
So for example?
例如？
Steel's a good example. We make steel with coal today, but we can make it with electricity. So let's do that.
钢铁是个好例子。我们今天用煤炭制造钢铁，但我们可以用电力制造。所以我们这么做。
OK, bucket three.
好的，领域三。
So bucket three, I'm thinking about waste. So there's two big things that I want us to stop wasting and that would get us a few more percentage points. So the first part of this is about reducing greenhouse gas emissions that we just are throwing in the atmosphere. We're just wasting them. The big one here is methane. So it's fixing leaky pipes. It's about plugging abandoned oil and gas wells, stopping putting methane into the atmosphere.
领域三，我考虑的是浪费。有两件大事我想让我们停止浪费，那样就能让我们多获得几个百分点。第一部分关于减少我们仅仅扔进大气的温室气体排放。我们只是在浪费它们。最大的一个是甲烷。所以是修复泄漏的管道。是堵塞废弃的油气井，停止将甲烷排放到大气中。
And the second kind?
第二种浪费？
The second kind of waste is the waste we have when it comes to zero carbon electricity. So we've already built a lot of wind turbines, a lot of nuclear power plants, a lot of solar panels. And we're not using all that at zero carbon electricity. We're just wasting a lot of it.
第二种浪费是我们拥有零碳电力时的浪费。我们已经建造了大量的风力涡轮机、核电站、太阳能电池板。而我们并没有使用所有的零碳电力。我们只是浪费了其中的很大一部分。
Like why?
为什么？
There's a bunch of different reasons. But it comes down to supply and demand not matching up.
有很多不同的原因。但归根结底是供需不匹配。
Is this a thing of like-- the solar energy gets made, but there's no way to store it and there's no way to get it to the homes where it's needed? Is that what you mean?
这是像……太阳能制造出来了，但没有储存方式，也没有办法把它传送到需要的家庭里吗？你是这个意思吗？
Yeah. And that's like-- it's such a waste, Ira. It's like, we already paid for it. It's already there. And we're not using it.
是的。那真是……太浪费了，艾拉。就像，我们已经付过钱了。它已经在那里了。而我们没在使用它。
And so to fix that, what do we do?
那么为了解决那个问题，我们该做什么？
So to fix that, we build a lot of wires to move the stuff around. And then we also figure out ways to store that electricity.
所以为了解决它，我们建造大量的电线来输送电力。然后我们也寻找储存电力的办法。
OK, so between those three buckets, you're saying that adds up to 10%. Can I ask you in the most real way possible, do you think that's actually going to happen? Are we actually going to get to 50% by 2030?
好的，在这三个领域之间，你说这加起来是10%。我能以最现实的方式问你吗？你认为那真的会发生吗？我们真的会在2030年之前达到50%吗？
I think we're going to get close. I don't know if we're going to get all the way there. I mean, we could overshoot it, honestly. There's a lot of different factors that go into that, including behavior, including broader things that are happening in the world that I have no insight into.
我认为我们会接近。我不知道我们是否能一路走到那里。我的意思是，老实说，我们甚至可能超额完成。有很多不同的因素会导致这一点，包括行为，包括世界上正在发生且我无法洞察的更广泛的事情。
What's going to keep us from maybe getting there as fast as we want is all the non-technical stuff. So being able to actually build something, get it permitted, get it paid for in our markets. I think it's going to be close. I don't know if we're going to get over the 50% line in time, though.
可能阻碍我们像我们希望的那样快速到达那里的，是所有非技术性的东西。所以能够真正建造某样东西，获得许可，在我们的市场上获得资助。我认为会很接近。但我不知道我们是否能及时跨过50%的线。
All right. Well, judges, what do you think?
好的。好吧，评委，你们怎么看？
Oh, wait. Wait, is this coming in? The judges say yes.
噢，等等。等等，这进来了吗？评委说yes。
Well, congratulations, Melissa, for winning round one.
好吧，恭喜你，梅丽莎，赢得了第一轮。
Thank you, Ira. Thank you, George. I appreciate it. But remember, this is only round one. There's another round after this.
谢谢你，艾拉。谢谢，乔治。我很感激。但请记住，这只是第一轮。后面还有一轮。
Well, exactly. That's exactly what I was going to say. You progressed to our bonus round. Let's talk about that next round, because the first goal that America set for itself with the Paris Agreement is to cut 50% of our emissions by 2030. But the bigger goal is to cut all greenhouse gases as far as possible to get to net zero by 2050. In your view, is there a credible path towards that that you can imagine actually happening?
嗯，完全正确。那正是我要说的。你晋级了我们的奖金轮。让我们谈谈那一轮，因为美国在《巴黎协定》中为自己设定的第一个目标是在2030年削减50%的排放量。但更大的目标是尽可能多地削减所有温室气体，到2050年实现净零排放。在你看来，你能想象出一条通往那里的可信路径吗？
There's definitely a credible path. I think there is. But like with the next eight years, it's going to be challenging and it requires us to make a choice to get on that path. And a lot of it is just doing a lot more of what we've already been talking about.
绝对有一条可信的路径。我认为有。但就像接下来的八年一样，这将会充满挑战，需要我们做出选择才能踏上那条路。而且很大程度上只是做更多我们已经谈过的事情。
Not just making more buildings more energy efficient. We're making every single building more energy efficient. We're electrifying those buildings. We're pulling all the emissions out of those buildings. We're getting every single car and truck and bus and plane to zero emissions. Every single thing in our transportation.
不仅仅是让更多的建筑提高能源效率。我们要让每一栋建筑都提高能效。我们要使这些建筑实现电气化。我们要把这些建筑里的所有排放物清理掉。我们要让每一辆汽车、卡车、公交车和飞机实现零排放。我们在运输中的每一件事。
When you say it this way, it just seems so big. It's hard to fathom that that could actually happen.
当你这样说时，它看起来太大了。很难想象那真的会发生。
I mean, it's massive. It is massive. It is a huge, huge undertaking. Some people describe it as like a wartime effort. I think that's right. Like it's massive to do this over the next just few decades. We're talking about 2050. That's not that long from now.
我的意思是，它是巨大的。它是巨大的。这是一项巨大、巨大的事业。有些人把它描述为一场战时努力。我认为那是对的。就像在接下来的几十年里做这件事是巨大的。我们谈论的是2050年。那距离现在并不长。
Well, that makes me feel not so super hopeful, just to say.
好吧，这让我感觉不那么超级有希望了，只能说。
But if we don't actually get there, we know the costs of inaction, of not moving there. And they're not pretty. So I'm talking about extreme events that flood Houston, or you know, swing across Florida. Heat waves in Southern California that lead to people dying. When you start to add up all these health costs and also the insurance costs, the cost of rebuilding homes, it's so much larger than building solar panels and nuclear power plants and retrofitting buildings and replacing cars.
但如果我们真的没能达到那里，我们知道不作为、不行动的代价。它们可不好看。所以我谈论的是淹没休斯顿的极端事件，或者横扫佛罗里达的灾难。南加州导致人员死亡的热浪。当你开始把所有这些健康成本，还有保险成本、重建房屋的成本加起来时，它比建造太阳能电池板、核电站、改造建筑和更换汽车要大得多。
Well, listen, thank you so much for playing our game. Let's bring in some inappropriately cheerful game show music. And George, tell her what she's won.
好吧，听着，非常感谢你参与我们的游戏。让我们来点不那么合适的游戏节目音乐。乔治，告诉她赢了什么。
Well, Melissa, how about a brand new SUV? Ooh. Two plane tickets to-- ugh. A subscription to Diesel and Steak Lovers magazine.
好吧，梅丽莎，一辆崭新的SUV怎么样？喔。两张飞往……呃。订阅《柴油和牛排爱好者》杂志。
What else you got there, buddy?
你还有什么别的，伙计？
Well, Melissa, this is perfect. How about autographed copies of the collected works of Bill McKibben?
好吧，梅丽莎，这太完美了。比尔·麦基本（Bill McKibben）全集的亲笔签名版怎么样？
That's more like it. Well, listen, thanks again, Melissa. And George, take it away.
那更像样了。好吧，听着，再次感谢你，梅丽莎。乔治，交给你了。
Thanks so much, everybody. And we'll see you next time, if we're not all fleeing a wildfire or hurricane on You Bet Your Planet's Life.
非常感谢大家。如果不是我们都在逃离野火或飓风，我们下次见，就在“拿你的行星生命打赌”节目。
Act 3-- You Didn't Hear It From Me. No, really, you didn't. This last game actually happened on another show, a podcast called Normal Gossip. And if you haven't heard Normal Gossip, the way it works, people in the show basically dish about actual gossip. Like true stories about normal, everyday people sent in by listeners.
第三幕——你没听我说过。不，真的，你没听过。这最后一个游戏实际上发生在另一个节目里，一个叫《Normal Gossip》的播客。如果你没听过《Normal Gossip》，它是这样运作的：节目中的人基本上会吐槽真正的八卦。就像听众寄来的关于普通人的真实故事。
And last season, the producers recreated a version of-- you know that old game, telephone, where somebody whispers something to the person next to them who whispers it to the person next to them and on down the line. One of our producers, Sean Cole, has this rundown of what happened when they did a version of that on Normal Gossip and how it revealed some interesting things about the stories that we tell each other. Here's Sean.
上一季，制作者重现了一个版本……你知道那个老游戏，传话游戏（telephone），某人对旁边的人低声说些什么，那个人再对旁边的人低声说，就这样一直传下去。我们的制作人之一，肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole），对他们在《Normal Gossip》做那个版本时发生的事情做了总结，它揭示了一些关于我们互相讲述的故事的有趣真相。这是肖恩。
The folks at Normal Gossip, they created the game for a very practical reason. While they were gearing up for season two, they got to talking about how long it had taken during season one for the guests to relax and settle into the conversation.
《Normal Gossip》的人们出于一个非常实际的原因创造了这个游戏。当他们为第二季做准备时，他们开始谈论第一季嘉宾放松并进入谈话状态需要多长时间。
And so we were having this brainstorming session where we were talking about ways that we could just give them some more time and space ahead of the recording to loosen up.
所以我们在开头脑风暴会议时，讨论如何能在录音前给他们更多的时间和空间来放松。
This is the producer of Normal Gossip, Alex Sujong Laughlin.
这是《Normal Gossip》的制作人，亚历克斯·苏琼·劳克林（Alex Sujong Laughlin）。
And I came up with this idea that what if we had them play a game that is a game of gossip?
我提出了一个想法，如果我们让他们玩一个关于八卦的游戏会怎样？
Gossip itself, of course, is sort of like a game of telephone. So they figured, let's just do that. Alex grabbed one of the gossip stories from their inbox and read it to the first guest that they had. And then recorded her telling it right back, just whatever that person could remember, played that for the second guest, had them tell it back and so on.
八卦本身，当然，有点像传话游戏。所以他们想，就这么办。亚历克斯从他们的收件箱里抓取了一个八卦故事，读给他们请来的第一位嘉宾听。然后录下她直接复述出来，就是那个人能记住的任何内容，然后放给第二位嘉宾听，让他们复述，以此类推。
I told them not to take notes, because you don't generally take notes when somebody's telling you a gossip story, right? You're not like--
我告诉他们不要做笔记，因为当有人给你讲八卦故事时，你通常不会做笔记，对吧？你不会像……
Unless you're a gossip columnist, I suppose.
除非你是八卦专栏作家，我猜。
Yeah, exactly. Unless you're me. So yeah, I said do the best you can. If you don't remember something, that's fine. If you feel like tweaking a detail for fun, you can.
是的，完全正确。除非你是像我这样的人。所以是的，我说尽力而为。如果你不记得什么，没关系。如果你觉得为了好玩想要调整一下细节，也可以。
But for the most part, try and be pretty faithful to the story you heard. Alex didn't really expect anything interesting to happen. But then when she listened through to all the versions, she realized she was seeing in real time how gossip works, how a story can evolve and change. That there was a logic to how it changed.
但大部分时候，尽量忠实于你听到的故事。亚历克斯其实没期望发生任何有趣的事。但当她听完所有版本时，她意识到她在实时观察八卦是如何运作的，一个故事如何演变和改变。关于它如何改变，是有逻辑的。
Sure, there was some willy-nilly embellishing here and there. But for the most part, the changes were for a very specific reason. And I'm going to get to that. But first, you need to hear the original version of the story, so that you can appreciate when we get there how different it was by the end of the game.
当然，到处都有随意的修饰。但大部分时候，改变是有非常具体的原因的。我要说到这一点。但首先，你需要听到故事的原始版本，这样当你听到最后时，你就能领会它是多么不同。
Yes, I have the text here.
是的，我有文本在这儿。
I asked Alex to read it to me. I should say with every gossip story they tell on the show, the names and all the identifying details are changed. So it's completely anonymized. This story concerns two people who they called Kyle and Elliot. They started dating sometime before the pandemic.
我让亚历克斯读给我听。我应该说，他们在节目中讲述的每一个八卦故事，名字和所有身份细节都被更改了。所以它是完全匿名化的。这个故事涉及两个人，他们称为凯尔（Kyle）和埃利奥特（Elliot）。他们在疫情前某个时间开始约会。
Kyle had grown up super religious and had been married to a woman. But he came out, left his family, left the church, and moved to the city where he met Elliot.
凯尔从小就超级虔诚，曾和一个女人结过婚。但他出柜了，离开了家庭，离开了教会，搬到了他遇到埃利奥特的城市。
And Elliot's really the main character of the story. You need to know that he's part of this active group chat with some college friends where they talk about their lives.
而埃利奥特确实是这个故事的主角。你需要知道他是一个与大学朋友活跃群聊的一员，他们在那里谈论他们的生活。
Everyone in the group chat was obsessed with Kyle. He was so warm, genuine, thoughtful. They move in together, adopt a cat, and are teaching it all kinds of tricks. Then Elliot proposes and Kyle proposes back. It's so adorable. The pandemic hits. And the group chat starts doing Zooms as you do. Usually, significant others pop in and say hi. And they all love to see Kyle.
群聊里的每个人都对凯尔着迷。他那么温暖、真诚、体贴。他们搬到一起住，领养了一只猫，并且正在教它各种各样的把戏。然后埃利奥特求婚，凯尔也求婚。真是太可爱了。疫情爆发。群聊开始用Zoom，就像你们做的那样。通常，另一半会跳出来打个招呼。他们都喜欢见到凯尔。
Around June, Elliot mentions that he's going home for a bit, doesn't mention Kyle. A few weeks later, the group Zooms and Kyle doesn't show up. They ask where he is. Elliot says, I didn't want to bring this up yet, but Kyle has actually left me. Turns out Kyle just packed up and disappeared. Left the cat, no explanation, ghosted his fiance. He disappeared off social media. And nobody knows where he went. Elliot is crushed.
六月左右，埃利奥特提到他要回家一会儿，没提凯尔。几周后，群聊Zoom，凯尔没出现。他们问他在哪儿。埃利奥特说，我还没想提这事，但凯尔其实离开我了。原来凯尔打包消失了。留下了猫，没解释，让他的未婚夫“幽灵般”地消失了。他在社交媒体上消失了。没人知道他去了哪儿。埃利奥特崩溃了。
So fast forward a year later. A friend of a friend is scrolling TikTok. And suddenly they see a viral video with Kyle. Turns out Kyle has reinvented himself on TikTok in the last year. He's suddenly super religious, but also still very much queer. He seems to spend his videos making a lot of references to leaving a toxic relationship and loving yourself. Our friend of a friend is like, what the fuck? Kyle has millions of views, tons of followers. Now we've tracked him down, but he's obviously obliquely talking shit about Elliot. What do you do? Do you tell Elliot?
所以快进一年。一个朋友的朋友正在刷TikTok。突然他们看到一个关于凯尔的病毒式视频。原来凯尔在过去一年在TikTok上重塑了自己。他突然超级虔诚，但也仍然非常酷儿（queer）。他似乎在视频中花了很多时间提及离开一段有毒的关系并爱你自己。我们那位朋友的朋友当时就想：什么鬼？凯尔有数百万播放量，大量粉丝。现在我们追踪到了他，但他显然是在含蓄地讲埃利奥特的坏话。你该怎么办？你告诉埃利奥特吗？
It ends with sort of a Dear Abby conundrum type question there. Anyway, that's where we start. There were eight guests listening to and repeating back some version of this story over the course of an eight week season. It was quite literally a long game. And I'll just tell you right now. The only parts of the story that didn't change practically at all were the very beginning.
它以一个类似“亲爱的艾比”（Dear Abby）的难题问题结束。总之，这就是我们的起点。有八位嘉宾在八周的季度中听并复述了这个故事的某个版本。这真是一个“长期游戏”。我就直接告诉你们吧。故事中几乎没有任何改变的部分是在非常开头的。
There were two guys in a relationship together.
有两个男人在一起谈恋爱。
Two guys. There is Elliot and there's Kyle, right?
两个男人。有埃利奥特和有凯尔，对吧？
A gay couple.
一对同性恋伴侣。
Elliot--
埃利奥特……
Elliot and Kyle.
埃利奥特和凯尔。
Meets Kyle.
遇到凯尔。
They start dating. They like each other. They move in together.
他们开始约会。他们喜欢对方。他们搬到一起住。
And the very end, where the friends see the TikTok video and ask themselves the question.
以及结尾，朋友们看到了TikTok视频并问自己那个问题。
And the question is--
问题是……
Do we tell Elliot or not?
我们告诉埃利奥特还是不告诉？
Do we tell Elliot?
我们告诉埃利奥特吗？
Should we tell him--
我们应该告诉他……
About this TikTok?
关于这个TikTok？
They don't know what they're supposed to do.
他们不知道他们该做什么。
Yeah, would you tell Elliot?
是的，你会告诉埃利奥特吗？
I'd tell Elliot in a heartbeat.
我会立刻告诉埃利奥特。
Almost everything else became completely unrecognizable. By the way, Tobin Low, who was in Act 1, happened to be a guest on Normal Gossip when they did this. Maybe you heard his voice in there. With the first couple of folks, the changes are relatively small. The very first guest, Danielle Henderson-- she's a TV writer-- she inserts this scene where Elliot discovers that Kyle has left.
几乎其他所有内容都变得完全无法辨认。顺便说一句，第一幕中的托宾·洛，恰好是他们在玩这个游戏时在《Normal Gossip》的嘉宾。也许你在里面听到了他的声音。在前几个人那里，改变相对较小。第一位嘉宾，丹妮尔·亨德森（Danielle Henderson）——她是一位电视编剧——她插入了一个场景，埃利奥特发现凯尔离开了。
And then he goes back to their apartment that they share, their place that they share. And Kyle is gone. He has packed up everything.
然后他回到他们共享的公寓，他们共享的地方。凯尔不见了。他收拾了一切。
But it's still the same plot as the original. The second person, Kalyn Kahler, who writes about sports-- when she heard Danielle say that Kyle packed up everything, seems to have taken that to mean everything.
但这仍然和原来的情节一样。第二个人，卡琳·卡勒（Kalyn Kahler），写体育报道的——当她听到丹妮尔说凯尔收拾了一切，似乎理解为“一切”。
Kyle is gone. The apartment is empty. There is no note. There is no trace of Kyle. It's like he never lived there. He probably took all his furniture and food and whatever.
凯尔不见了。公寓是空的。没有纸条。没有凯尔的踪迹。就像他从没在那住过一样。他可能拿走了他所有的家具和食物什么的。
She also-- I think inadvertently-- leaves out a pretty important detail at the end, the fact that Kyle is still gay. Probably just didn't think to mention it. Besides that, she casually ad libs this kind of loose dialogue in the beginning where Elliot's friends are all aflutter about meeting Kyle.
她还——我想是不经意地——漏掉了结尾一个相当重要的细节，凯尔仍然是同性恋的事实。可能只是没想起来提。除此之外，她在开头随口加入了一些松散的对话，埃利奥特的朋友们对见到凯尔感到非常兴奋。
Everyone is very curious, like who's Kyle? Elliot, introduce us to Kyle. We want to meet your new boyfriend. Like you're so happy, how are things going?
大家都很好奇，比如凯尔是谁？埃利奥特，介绍我们认识凯尔。我们想见你的新男朋友。就像你这么开心，事情进展如何？
But those few alterations set us up for some real misunderstandings that are about to take off with the third person, Tracy Clayton of the podcast Strong Black Legends. She hears this part.
但那几次改动为接下来的真实误解埋下了伏笔，那些误解在第三个人，播客“Strong Black Legends”的特蕾西·克莱顿（Tracy Clayton）身上爆发了。她听到了这一部分。
Everyone is very curious, like who's Kyle? Elliot, introduce us to Kyle.
大家都很好奇，比如凯尔是谁？埃利奥特，介绍我们认识凯尔。
And takes it to mean that the friend group never does meet Kyle, which is very different. That and the missing detail of Kyle still being gay leads to this ending from Tracy. Again, the friends are scrolling TikTok.
并把它理解为朋友群从未见过凯尔，这非常不同。那加上凯尔仍然是同性恋这一细节的缺失，导致了特蕾西给出的这个结局。再次，朋友们在刷TikTok。
And so they come across a TikTok of a very evangelical, like born-again Christian, very strict. Everything that's not in the Bible is wrong type of person. And he's just going off and saying all of this terrible stuff. And probably very anti-trans, anti anti-racism, anti-everything good. And it's just going off about all this wild stuff. But then this man starts talking about this terrible, toxic relationship that he was in. And dropping all these hints, but not really saying too much, so nobody really knew if he was talking about Elliot or not. But the friends are like, he's definitely talking about Elliot. That's so fucked up.
所以他们刷到一个TikTok，非常福音派，类似重生的基督教，非常严格。所有不在《圣经》里的东西都是错误类型的人。他只是在走火入魔，说所有这些糟糕透顶的话。而且可能非常反跨、反反种族主义、反一切美好的事物。只是在谈论所有这些疯狂的事情。但后来这个人开始谈论他身处的一段可怕、有毒的关系。并掉落了所有暗示，但并没有真正说太多，所以没人真正知道他是不是在谈论埃利奥特。但朋友们想：他绝对是在谈论埃利奥特。那太混蛋了。
Also, this new, somewhat more sinister version of Kyle took even more from the apartment than he did before.
而且，这个凯尔的新版本，在某种程度上更邪恶，他比以前从公寓里带走了更多东西。
The cat is gone.
猫也不见了。
First mention of Kyle taking the cat with him. All of those embellishments are crystallized and even built upon in the fourth iteration of the story, which is sort of tag team told by Bobby Finger and Lindsey Weber, who host another gossip podcast called Who? Weekly. More than anyone else, they really tried to imagine themselves into the heads of the friend group. Like when Elliot tells them, I just moved in with this guy Kyle and we got a cat together.
第一次提到凯尔带着猫走了。所有这些修饰在故事的第四次迭代中结晶甚至被建立起来，这次是由“Who? Weekly”八卦播客的主持人鲍比·芬格（Bobby Finger）和林赛·韦伯（Lindsey Weber）接力讲述的。他们比任何人都更努力地想象自己进入朋友群的脑子里。比如当埃利奥特告诉他们：我刚和这个叫凯尔的家伙搬到一起住，我们还一起养了只猫。
And his friends are assumedly like, who? How do we not know this person? Why-- you moved in with somebody. You got a cat with them. And we don't even know who it is. But you know what, we're so happy for you. We're going to feel positive about this. This is how I would feel, I guess, if a friend of mine did this to me. Although I would be a little mad, but that's OK. That's my thing. Not these people--
他的朋友们想必会想：是谁？我们怎么会不知道这个人？为什么……你和某人搬到一起住。你和他们养了只猫。而我们甚至不知道他是谁。但你知道吗，我们为你开心。我们要对此保持积极态度。我想如果我的朋友对我这么做，我也会这么觉得。虽然我会有点生气，但没关系。那是我的事。不是这些人……
I'd feel a little sus. In the back of my head, I'd be a little sus.
我会觉得有点可疑。在我脑海深处，我会觉得有点可疑。
Yeah, because you can't just drop in the group chat that's active all fucking day long, oh, hey, by the way, I live with someone and we have a cat.
是的，因为你不能在全天候活跃的群聊里随手发：噢，嘿，顺便说一下，我和某人住在一起，我们还有只猫。
Yeah, I get the feeling the friends haven't even like seen a photo-- or the friends have seen a photo. Wait, no, the friends have not seen a photo. I think the friends never even saw a photo of this person.
是的，我觉得朋友们甚至没见过照片……或者朋友们见过照片。等等，不，朋友们没见过照片。我想朋友们甚至没见过这个人的照片。
Bobby, we're telling the story. It's our story, so you can say that if you just want to say.
鲍比，我们在讲故事。这是我们的故事，所以如果你只想说，你可以说。
The friends never saw a photo of this person. They don't even know what this person looks like. They just know their name is Kyle.
朋友们从没见过这个人的照片。他们甚至不知道这个人长什么样。他们只知道他叫凯尔。
You get the sense, listening to Bobby and Lindsey, that they know they're embellishing some of the details. But they're also hewing pretty closely to the basic plot points they heard in Tracy Clayton's version. So Kyle robs Elliot blind, takes the cat. Elliot's crushed. The friends are trying to be supportive.
听鲍比和林赛讲，你会感觉到他们知道自己在修饰某些细节。但他们也紧紧跟随他们从特蕾西·克莱顿版本听到的基本情节。所以凯尔把埃利奥特洗劫一空，带走了猫。埃利奥特崩溃了。朋友们在试图给予支持。
The friends are-- one of them, at least, is on their TikTok page on their FYP--
朋友们……至少其中一个，在他们的TikTok页面FYP上……
FYP is the For You page.
FYP就是“For You”页面。
And on the FYP is a video of an evangelical TikTok influencer who is apparently extremely religious, extremely fundamentalist, has really problematic opinions--
而在FYP上是一个福音派TikTok网红的视频，显然极其虔诚，极其原教旨主义，有真正成问题的观点……
And is viral.
而且病毒式传播。
And is like, here's my lifestyle. I'm viral for these horrible opinions. Oh, look at my cute cat Greg. And then the friends are like, wait--
并且像：这是我的生活方式。我因这些可怕的观点而病毒式传播。噢，看我可爱的猫格雷格（Greg）。然后朋友们想：等等……
Wait, I have another twist. He's like, I'm straight. That's the--
等等，我还有另一个转折。他说：我是直的。那就是……
Right. Yes.
没错。是的。
Like he's like, I was in this awful relationship, but I found God. Here's my cat, Greg.
就像他说：我曾处于那段糟糕的关系中，但我找到了上帝。这是我的猫，格雷格。
I'm straight.
我是直的。
And my ex was toxic. And the friends see the TikTok and they're sharing it. And they're like, is this about Elliot?
而且我的前任是有毒的。朋友们看到了TikTok，他们在分享它。他们说：这是关于埃利奥特的吗？
This, of course, is a huge change. They're naming the cat Greg. I'm kidding. The fact of Kyle now being straight. Funnily, this is the first iteration of the story where the detail of Kyle being previously married to a woman was left out. So in the original, Kyle was with a woman in the beginning of the story. Now he's with women at the end. And more and more, Kyle is becoming a villain. Until by the fifth telling of the story, he's out and out malicious, even criminal. That version, the fifth one, was the one told by our very own Tobin Low.
这，当然，是一个巨大的改变。他们给猫取名格雷格。我开玩笑的。凯尔现在是直的这一事实。有趣的是，这是故事中第一个省略了凯尔曾与一个女人结婚这一细节的版本。所以原来，凯尔在故事开头是和一个女人在一起。现在他在结尾和女人们在一起。而且，凯尔变得越来越反派。直到故事的第五次讲述，他变得彻底邪恶，甚至是犯罪。那个版本，第五个版本，是托宾·洛本人讲述的。
They are also getting a cat together. Let's call the cat Mr. Mistoffelees from Cats the musical, as one does.
他们也养了只猫。我们叫这只猫“米斯托菲里斯先生”（Mr. Mistoffelees），来自音乐剧《猫》，就像人们通常会做的那样。
And I know this will sound biased because I work with him. But his version is really one of my favorites in this reverse Groundhog Day movie about Elliot and Kyle.
我知道这听起来有偏见，因为我和他一起工作。但他的版本真的在这个关于埃利奥特和凯尔的“反转土拨鼠日”电影中是我最喜欢的版本之一。
Cut to one of his friends in the middle of the night scrolling through TikTok, as one does, comes across a TikTok on their For You page. And it is this guy talking about how he catfishes people. His whole thing is that he pretends to be gay. He gets in these relationships.
切换到他的一位朋友在半夜刷TikTok，就像人们通常会做的那样，在他们的For You页面看到一个TikTok。是一个家伙在谈论他是如何欺骗（catfish）人的。他的整个套路就是假装自己是同性恋。他卷入这些关系中。
He's actually like a very religious, conservative person. And so he's like catfishing these dudes to be in relationships with him. And it's all a sham. It's all a sham. And so then he goes into like I recently did this to a guy. We got a cat together, Mr. Mistoffelees. And then I took him for all he's worth. And actually, it was a really bad toxic relationship.
他其实是一个非常虔诚、保守的人。所以他在欺骗这些男人进入和他那种关系。那全是个骗局。全是个骗局。然后他谈到我最近对一个家伙做了这种事。我们一起养了只猫，米斯托菲里斯先生。然后我掏空了他所有的钱。而且实际上，那是一段非常糟糕、有毒的关系。
Did you hear what happened there? Basically, Tobin took these loose facts from Bobby and Lindsey's telling-- the empty apartment, Kyle being straight, and very religious and conservative-- and he combines all those things.
你听到发生了什么吗？基本上，托宾把鲍比和林赛讲述的那些松散的事实——空荡荡的公寓、凯尔是直的、而且非常虔诚保守——结合了所有那些东西。
Into a catfishing scam artist, who is not only doing that, but bragging about it on TikTok.
变成了一个骗子，不仅如此，还在TikTok上炫耀。
This is Alex again, the Normal Gossip producer.
这是亚历克斯，《Normal Gossip》的制作人。
Which seems to me like-- honestly, this is the turn that makes the least logical sense to me. Sorry, Tobin. But like if he's a scam artist, why would you be bragging about it? Then your scam is ruined. You know?
这对我来说……老实说，这是逻辑上最不通的转弯。抱歉，托宾。但如果他是骗子，为什么你要炫耀？那你的骗局不就毁了吗？你知道吗？
I hadn't even thought of that.
我甚至没想过那个。
And it's funny, because Tobin has said multiple times, he thought he was telling it perfectly.
很有趣，因为托宾多次说过，他以为他讲得非常完美。
I stand by what I said. I thought that I told it exactly as it was told to me.
我坚持我说的。我以为我讲得和我听到的完全一样。
This, of course, is my colleague Tobin Low. He deigned to consent to an interview for this story.
这，当然，是我的同事托宾·洛。他屈尊同意接受这个故事的采访。
And if you had asked me afterwards, the only liberty I was very conscious of taking was changing the cat's name, which I thought was just fun and harmless.
如果你事后问我，我唯一有意识采取的自由就是改了猫的名字，我觉得那只是有趣且无害的。
To be fair, Bobby did use the word scam one time in his and Lindsey's telling of the story. But there was nothing about catfishing. And certainly no mention of multiple victims of same. Tobin ultimately heard the original version of the story. And I had to wonder what he thought about it.
公平地说，鲍比在他和林赛的故事讲述中确实用过一次“诈骗”这个词。但没有任何关于钓鱼欺诈（catfishing）的内容。更不用说多个受害者。托宾最终听到了故事的原始版本。我不禁想知道他对它有什么看法。
I think I was surprised that they were happy at one point. Or like they had a really good relationship.
我想我惊讶的是他们曾经一度很开心。或者他们曾经有一段很好的关系。
Right.
对。
I think that I would have assumed that that would survive in some way in the retellings. The original's just kind of sad. And then it becomes extraordinary in a way that like by the end, people's hurt is not the focus.
我想我会假设那会以某种方式在复述中存活下来。原版故事只是有点悲伤。然后它变得非凡，以至于到最后，人们的伤痛不再是焦点。
Yeah.
是的。
It's like sort of how wild people's actions are and like you've sort of drifted far away from the original, smaller, more human hurt.
就像人们的行为是多么疯狂，你已经从最初的、更小的、更人性化的伤痛中漂移得很远了。
And he has a theory as to how they all collectively got there.
他有一个关于他们如何集体走到那一步的理论。
In retrospect, I think what happened is that everyone knew that there was this thing coming in the story where Kyle was going to leave Elliot. And that's sort of like-- all roads lead to this big moment in the story. And I think to some degree, we were all reverse engineering to that moment. Like how do you explain the beats of what happened? How do you explain everyone's actions, so that that makes sense and lands really hard?
回想起来，我想发生的事情是每个人都知道故事里有这一幕，凯尔要离开埃利奥特。那是……所有的路都通向故事里的这个大时刻。我想在某种程度上，我们都在对那个时刻进行“逆向工程”。你如何解释发生了什么？你如何解释每个人的行为，使之说得通且非常震撼？
Right.
对。
So that you recreate the same gasp that you had when you heard it.
这样你就能重现你听到它时的那个惊叹。
Right.
对。
So that I can create that moment again.
这样我就能再次创造那个时刻。
Because in the original, there is no explanation. And you're just kind of like, what the heck?
因为在原版里，没有任何解释。你只是有点像……什么鬼？
Yes.
是的。
And that's an uncomfortable feeling.
那是一种不舒服的感觉。
Right, exactly.
对，完全正确。
Just like it is in life. But of course, as Tobin had to remind me, the original story is life. That version wasn't part of a game. It really happened. Weirdly, there was only one more major change to the story after Tobin's version. When the comedian Brian Park tells it next, the guy in the TikTok video is not Kyle but one of Kyle's many unsuspecting victims, warning other TikTokers to watch out for this predator, which of course, makes a lot more sense. Oh, and there's no mention of them getting a cat.
就像生活中一样。但当然，正如托宾提醒我的那样，原版故事就是生活。那个版本不是游戏的一部分。它确实发生了。奇怪的是，在托宾的版本后，故事又发生了一个重大改变。当喜剧演员布莱恩·朴（Brian Park）接下来讲述它时，TikTok视频里的家伙不再是凯尔，而是凯尔众多毫无戒心的受害者之一，警告其他TikTok用户提防这个捕食者，这当然更有道理。噢，也没提到他们养猫。
And then the two versions after that are basically identical to Brian's. It's like there were no more questions to be answered. No gaps in understanding. All of the reverse engineering Tobin talked about was complete, which makes you wonder if there's a natural end to a game like this. If you can only retell the story so many times before it plateaus, stays static.
然后接下来的两个版本基本上和布莱恩的一样。就像没有更多问题需要解答了。理解上没有空白。托宾提到的所有逆向工程都完成了，这让你好奇像这样的游戏是否有自然的终点。如果你只能在它变平稳、保持静态之前复述这个故事这么多遍。
I bet you that happens to urban myths, too. Alex Sujong Laughlin says watching the story go through all of those changes was kind of thrilling. It was like seeing your own little monster come alive on the laboratory table. But by the last couple two, three versions of the story, she had this other feeling as well.
我敢说都市神话也会发生这种情况。亚历克斯·苏琼·劳克林说，看着故事经历所有那些改变有点惊心动魄。就像看着你自己的一只小怪物在实验室的桌子上活过来。但在故事的最后两三个版本中，她也有了另一种感觉。
It makes me feel sad.
它让我感到难过。
Why?
为什么？
It makes me think of the way that people become caricatures to each other. And it just feels like, you know, I don't know. Not to be all didactic and stuff, but we're talking the night before election day. And I've watched this play out for months, the way that people just get flattened into you know, conservative rednecks who hate everybody or radical feminazis who want to kill babies.
它让我想起人们如何成为彼此的漫画。这感觉就像，你知道，我不知道。不是要讲大道理什么的。但我们正在谈论选举日的前一天。我观看了这几个月里发生的事情，人们被扁平化为你知道的，讨厌所有人的保守派红脖子，或者是想杀掉婴儿的激进女权主义者。
Right.
对。
And it just-- it bums me out to see it happen so quickly, even in such a low stakes story.
看到它发生得这么快，即使在一个风险这么低的故事里，也让我很丧。
It's sort of like all of us are playing the game, all the time.
就像我们所有人一直在玩那个游戏。
Yeah. And like maybe in those moments when you feel like you want to jump to a conclusion or flatten somebody because it makes the story better, maybe don't. You know? Maybe don't. I don't know. I would like to create fewer of these monster Kyles, even if they're fictional.
是的。就像也许在那些你想跳向结论或贬低某人因为这让故事更好的时刻，也许别这么做。你知道吗？也许别这么做。我不知道。我想创造更少的这些怪物凯尔，即使它们是虚构的。
That seems like a worthy slogan on behalf of decency and fairness to others. Let's create fewer monster Kyles. Only a handful of people in the world would understand what it means, of course. But just like the juiciest gossip, maybe it would spread.
那似乎是一个代表正派和对他人公平的值得的口号。让我们创造更少的怪物凯尔。当然，世界上只有少数人会明白那意味着什么。但就像最有趣的八卦，也许它会传播。
Sean Cole is one of the producers of our program. To hear the full episode that Normal Gossip did where all this plays out, you can find that and their other episodes wherever you get your podcasts. By the way, the friends did tell Elliot about the TikTok. He laughed.
肖恩·科尔是我们节目的制作人之一。要听《Normal Gossip》所做的完整剧集以及这一切如何上演，你可以在你获取播客的任何地方找到那一期以及他们的其他剧集。顺便说一句，朋友们确实告诉了埃利奥特那个TikTok。他笑了。
Our program was produced today by Tobin Low. People who put together today's show include Elna Baker, Chris Benderev, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Michal Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Valerie Kipnis, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Charlotte Sleeper, Lilly Sullivan, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
我们今天的节目由托宾·洛制作。制作今天节目的包括埃尔纳·贝克（Elna Baker）、克里斯·本德雷夫（Chris Benderev）、佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace）、肖恩·科尔、米哈尔·科米特（Michal Comite）、阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德（Aviva DeKornfeld）、瓦莱丽·基普尼斯（Valerie Kipnis）、斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katherine Rae Mondo）、纳迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）、瑞安·鲁梅里（Ryan Rumery）、夏洛特·斯利珀（Charlotte Sleeper）、莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）、弗朗西斯·斯旺森（Frances Swanson）、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）、朱莉·惠特克（Julie Whitaker）和黛安·吴。我们的执行编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼（Sarah Abdurrahman）。我们的高级编辑是戴维·克 the stenbaum（David Kestenbaum）。我们的执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·贝里（Emanuele Berry）。
Special thanks today to John Bistline, Cen Qian, Justin Ellis, Kelsey McKinney, Jae Towle-Viera, and Geoff Triplett. Melissa Lott, our contestant in the climate game show-- she has a podcast of her own, The Big Switch, about the transition to a net zero world. Our website, where right now you can find all kinds of merch-- onesies, t-shirts, sweatshirts, Public Radio tattoos for your holiday shopping-- thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Special thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He's actually on his way to the office right now, probably because I sent him this.
今天特别感谢约翰·比斯特莱恩（John Bistline）、岑谦（Cen Qian）、贾斯汀·埃利斯（Justin Ellis）、凯尔西·麦金尼（Kelsey McKinney）、杰·托尔-维埃拉（Jae Towle-Viera）和杰夫·特里普利特（Geoff Triplett）。梅丽莎·洛特，我们在气候游戏节目中的参赛者……她自己有一个播客《大转换》（The Big Switch），关于向净零世界的转型。我们的网站，现在你可以在那里找到各种周边——连体衣、T恤、卫衣、公共广播纹身，为你的节日购物——thisamericanlife.org。《This American Life》由公共广播交换平台PRX传送给公共广播电台。像往常一样，特别感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。他现在正前往办公室的路上，大概是因为我发了这个给他。
Torey Malatia, come on down. You're the next contestant on This American Life.
托里·马拉蒂亚，快请进。你是《This American Life》的下一位参赛者。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week, with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带来更多《This American Life》的故事。